ich habe jemanden wie viel wir auf jeden
fall mehr als 48 ich bin wieder ein
bisschen hallo und herzlich willkommen
bei minecraft warum dem kompost
doch was ich dir gerade nochmal für den
tipp geben wollte wer gibt mir hinten
strip meinst ich weiß das geht quasi gar
nicht dass uns gegenseitig tipps geben
können weil wir einfach beide nichts
wissen
wenn wir beide strip meine reifen hacke
um dich vor zu haben
unterschätzt du überschätzt mich mal
wieder
ich habe mich einfach jegliche lover zu
die mir begegnet das problem ist jetzt
gar nicht du hast ja auch super luca du
bist ja der berner das ja masken
spitzhacken gemacht hier ohne ende
wieder gesagt liegt also eine kiste du
ich hab mich gerade überlassen
das ist ja grandios wenn nicht andere
lag unter noch einmal ein block von mir
die ich gesetz habe nicht da ist dann
ebenfalls in la ist okay ich werde mich
da draußen ein bisschen mit dem
wassereimer und mache alles vor zehn
jahren warum dann nicht gleich so warum
denn nicht gleich so
das ist die frage die sich luca jeden
morgen stellt diese persönlich
jedenfalls nicht irgendein interesse
dann aber ohne spaß es geht heftig
schnell
ich habe mir zwar nuzman ratten gefunden
und nichts anderes zack und designer
oder hat sogar eine schaufel rente mit
der schaufel durch die gegend dass er
ganz schön krass aber wir werden dir ich
kann jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich den
sonnenaufgang beobachten was wäre ich
mal weg das hier
hallo herr hopp hatte lacht kannst du
nur beobachten kann ich nur beobacht
wenn ich was bin ich möchte ja ich
möchte hier die ganze zeit mir ein
bisschen okubo wo ist sie denn die sonne
auf das hat ja das hat ja auch niemand
das hat mir noch niemand die zeit
genommen ein bisschen die sonne zurzeit
bei den ganzen wald anzuzünden hat
einfach den ganzen wald an zuzügen ist
wenn wir uns raus und dann nach rechts
da sollte eigentlich nicht mehr so viel
wald sei es so ist dann bist du ein
bisschen was da also genug um entspannt
ab soll sich sogar das essen bieten die
pilzsuppe haben die die haben auch
irgendwann täglich erstmal eine weil die
piste besser für pvp dann ja ja jetzt
geht's erst mal wieder rein ich weiß ja
irgendwie so dass man schnell sinken
könnte aber ich hab sie ich hab sie
einfach gebietet staunt jetzt mache ich
uns erstmal mehrere kisten also nochmal
eine wo so dreckschwein kann direkt
schießt durch kommt wieder so zackig so
viel aber ich bin so nah an der laaber
hierbei sag ich angst habe ich jetzt
mache ich erstmal unser unter
unterschiedlichen a.main boden könnte
ich auch mal weiter hier so zack da
kommt das schild bitte das schild ich
kann das nicht an die dinge dann machen
wir das auch so mit mit dicken
funktioniert alles cool alles cool ich
finde nichts geht ich finde keine
du gehst nach lava ich sehe nur lava mal
nicht du gibst in der höhe und finde es
einfach direkt diamanten ja hier ist es
so ich geh 101 ich finde ist alles außer
diamanten sind jetzt max goldt alles
mögliche bei dir ist halt da fehlt da
fehlt da fehlt der väter spirit das wort
es war ihr seht da ist er wieder der
profi am start gewesen mit seiner kiste
so hat ihn schon wieder schmeckt was
martinsmarkt 54 der match hat man hier
ist nur scheiße ich könnte mich
umbringen junge hier ist nicht optimal
aber nur so viel das sparpaket schon
wieder schmack des israelisch maraghy
das hier ist nur lava das ist so traurig
links mit einer gold ja immer etwas was
ich schon immer mal sagen würde luca mit
goldenen äpfel bekommt man zwei herz
mehr kaputt ja ein bisschen aber das
kann man gleich wieder weg ins umzubauen
ich muss noch provisorisch mit kobil
obwohl ich hier jemand gleich koppel mit
diamant blöcken irgendwie ganz gut und
passend
ich krieg die krise in den ofen schieben
nicht hier so 20 zoll stellt mal laut
mal gleich aber jetzt muss ich auch hier
überall die erde wieder aufbessern man
jetzt darf ich hier so gartenarbeit
macht nur bei der kripo auch ja spreche
ich mich mal in die luft ich hab dort
jemanden wie viel das ist perfekt aber
es ist richtig richtig gut wie wir uns
einfach ergänzen und ich könnte jetzt
kann er uns wirklich die schärfe drei
machen auf jeden fall und du kannst ihn
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie eine hose
dazu pack und nicht nur schule also ich
möchte wirklich einfach nochmal erwähnen
dass ich so unglaublich stolz auf uns
da musst du erst einmal selbst ein
schulterklopfer geben also ich bin
einfach so stolz auf uns metzner ohne
witz
richtig stark was wir machen und mein
unterleib hat aufgehört zu zittern
obwohl ich geredet habe ja hat aufgehört
das ist einfach weil weil die diamanten
nicht so glücklich machen was ich weiß
was ich schon immer mal sagen wollte
nehmen du bist da ich es wie ein vulkan
bricht mich daran
ich komme nach atome fackeln ich gebe
weiter strippen und ich glaube das ist
ganz ganz gut weil wenn ich jetzt auch
mal die ersten arten von hab dann kann
die nächsten eigentlich nur folgen dann
bin ich einfach erst mal so ein bisschen
draußen ja und und guck mich darum ob
ich vielleicht noch mal irgendwo was
soll ich mit dem jemand machen ich packe
ich erst mal unsere projekte gesten der
macht das macht das sonst auch gerne
sortieren gar kein gar kein ding alles
hass auf draußen ich will nicht dass
einer von uns beiden steht und ich das
hier alleine zur welt kommt ich will
nicht dass einer von uns stirbt nicht
dass er leider weiter kommentiert
ausgeschlossen ist dass ich sterbe gar
keinen sinn also wenn jemand stirbt dann
definitiv gleich ich auf jeden fall
ich habe die ganze nacht nicht gefunden
eingelegt haben wir da sind
ich hab grad ich habe gerade namen
gesehen aber es ist möglich dass wir
sind ja wir sind immer allein also ich
kann mich an keine folgen
delay oder oliven mal drauf wir uns am
anfang am anfang an crafter und aber die
haben es halt beide teams nichts getan
ich habe ich fast von den kohleblock
erschrecken hinkriegen also das ist das
ist echt so ein richtiges easy going
bisher sonst eine landing von uns
während woanders vielleicht auch mal
ganz entspannt ich glaube wenn einfach
in allen folgen immer mega die action
abgeht und alle total und spannung sind
wir sind natürlich auch weil wir wollen
euch nicht enttäuschen dass das projekt
angeht aber erheben ist spannung bei
jedem europa nur halb tot
aber das ist glaube ich das ist glaube
ich auch mal ganz cool weil das das gibt
zumindest so dass das zeigt auch das
wasser einmal etwas ruhiges auch genau
das was am anfang so als kritik auch
gebracht wurde am projekt waren daher
ein größeres video dazu gemacht dass das
das halt mega langweilig wird und
irgendwie niemand mehrere folgen machen
wird können das ist ja da sind wir
bisher das gegenbeispiel für ja also wir
können dann wirklich auch folge machen
die vom vom kommentare was haben wir
haben unsere basis ist wie ihr wir haben
unsere lustigen momente und ich glaube
nicht dass es keine
einfach alle bei uns ist das beste gibt
nichts besseres angebot hat er noch
nicht sagen jeder soll das gucken bei
dem er bock drauf hat aber ich hätte zum
beispiel wenn ich ihr werden wobei mir
bock ich glaube ich ein alter das
zuckerrohr bextor ja ist wächst ist okay
jetzt sind haben wir solche
glücksmomente hier am start
es wird unglaublich ist wächst endlich
so ich mache hier unsere unsere basis
unserer basis eingang wieder wieder
richtig hat eine mutter da auch erst mal
schön applaudiert hier naja du hast dir
es sich gerade draußen ab du das ist
nicht mehr von dieser welt
ich glaub ich geh wieder in die höhle
des stuttmann ist nicht so mein ding ich
finde da auf andere wege lieber die
diamanten
wir haben die das markt erinnert mich
immer so an diamanten
das ist immer so ein richtiges fading
ich probiere ich mache mir hier oben
gerade nochmal ab so und versucht dann
gleich nochmal gericht mir dass das
heißt bin ich für ein buch obwohl wir
haben doch das reichte glaube ich oder
reicht mir das ist ein 2 da brauche ich
das gleich mal noch mal an hier und dann
können wir die spieler versuchen mit
büchern zu verkauft weil das noch ein
bisschen billiger als wenn ich jetzt
jedes mal hier
du warst schon was macht also mit den
richtigen schweren verzaubern
obwohl ich das jetzt mal machen werde
ich mache mir jetzt komme ich nehme zwei
diaz und gucke mich auf stufe 3 chf 3,3
warum machst du das denn das ist das
macht doch keinen sinn wenn du es
ausprobiert dann probiert es doch lieber
im singleplayer aus dass diese diamanten
verschwindest die dkd verzauberungen ja
die kommen
die kannst du nicht auswendig lernen das
ist die kannst du nicht übersetzen oder
so es kommt meistens schärfe eins raus
oder oder oder nicht bei den büchern ist
es halt unwahrscheinlicher aber bei den
schwertern kommt ja als er gemerkt
unsere unsere tier schwer da habe ich
durch die die schwerter
verzögerungstaktik ganz leicht auf
zeugen kommen soll ich es ausprobieren
die am 8 wir haben wirklich viele
diamanten probiert es aus
ich probiere es aus es ist schärfe 1 oh
mein gott ich kann zwei statt drei
verzaubern esther stark muss ich aber
gucken würde wenn ich hier ich kann es
nur wiederholen ich bin stolz aber ich
glaub ich glaube wir brauchen wir
brauchen dann wir brauchen dann zwei auf
das wird richtig teuer alter das wird
richtig teuer die muss nämlich erst
ich muss dann noch mal eins auf schärfe
1 machen und dann quasi zwei schärfe
zweites schärfe 2 gibt es scharfe 3 und
das feuer im block auf bücher haben oder
wie es ist nämlich habe somit den das
hast du doch gesehen ich habe mit den
büchern probiert ja wir können es auch
weiter mit den büchern probieren aber
dann starb ein trend mehr sondern fällt
alles wohl alles cool ja alles in
ordnung machte keinen kopf aber dass das
das kriegen wir noch zwölf teams übrig
es ist alles cool gebracht gerade ist
alles cool es immerhin noch alles guten
analysen des plans ist so eine scheiße
dass ich mal schutz drauf
grundsätzlich machen wenn wir irgendwie
bei lara sind dass wir einfach ein fall
weil die uns halt kennen ja das stimmt
ich finde es absolut schön es gibt ja so
eine wahre und news twitter seite beim 1
1 23
okay okay ich krieg immer nur dreck bei
meinen beim 1
bei meinen bei meinen reisen rüstungen
ich habe einfach ich krieg den eispanzer
immer nur auf schuss sicher was will ich
damit schuss sicher ich will should do
drecksspiel hat weiß dass ich da werde
ich auch wirklich da wenig aggressiv
bring mal auch wirklich eisen hätte ein
unterhalt wieder an zu zittern
fängt mein unterlagen also ich hab also
in die kiste gelegt also sollte ein
bisschen was dran sein
ok ok ich hab' ich hab versucht ihren
bus panzer mit schutz draußen alles
wieder so schusssicher geworden bei
kommerzieller kritischen aspekte oder
findet ihr auch wieder nur sch markt
ich habe mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
hier auf dem weg und der kunde die
gegend um uns herum das kann auch nicht
schaden
ja da kann ja nicht schaden
das heißt ich erkunde unten sind die
höhlen duell kommt es oben so ein
bisschen ja ich gucke ich gucke mich
noch so ein bisschen um vielleicht
vielleicht finde ich irgendwie basis
oder nimmt am besten wirklich alle kohle
mit aber einfach so ab dass es auf so
nah wie vor die zeit im blick mein
freund du selbstverständlich zehn
minuten gut also wird gut gut gut gut
daran dass ich das nicht vergessen
zehn minuten sind wir gerade alles klar
dann merke ich mir auch bei mir so ein
bisschen was ich habe ich habe eine
höhle gefunden
da springe ich auch mal gleich voller
freude springe ich da hinein
auch goldene äpfel seiner versuche äpfel
zu bekommen ich hab so viel gold hier
unten
ja ich gucke ich gucke da durch die
höhle war nichts das war eine eine eine
schlechte höhle aber vielleicht freut
sich jemand wenn er die packen sie
wieder den polio mittels gefunden
aber wer hat bisher die basis geplündert
weiß wer was der bass team und produktiv
war schon selbst so betitelt es war auch
sehr witzig wie er die bälle einfach
nicht darauf kommen ist das team um prof
tiflis hinten befördert liebe es war
noch mal gucken dass ich hier die
orientierung nicht verlieren und auch
wieder zurückfinden weil das passiert
passiert mir sehr sehr schnell ich bin
wieder so nah hier in ähnlichen dingen
die mir gefährlich werden können ja bist
du das bin ich ich bin so ein richtiger
berg grills sage ich mir doch immer noch
dass banken so groß ist irgendwo ich
habe unsere basis von nur dass hier oder
krippen jetzt erst mal ein bisschen ruhe
reinbringen oder ja dass das wir dass
wir unsere basis
hallo ja das war sie also basis so gut
versteckt dass ich sie wieder erkennen
die koordinaten jahr biggs ja alles klar
dass wir einige haben in die kommentare
schreiben
ihr seid doch dumm wegen der fans kämpft
ihr nicht nur eure eigenen koordinaten
des spiels haben wir schon die facetime
da drin das ist nicht in der
nachbearbeitung dass es einfach während
des spiels schon erreichen projiziert
damit wir selbst nicht mal unsere
koordinaten kennen damit dass noch
sicherer ist richtig richtig damit wenig
versehen wir sind so die das haben wir
uns natürlich gleich da hab ich noch das
hat man ja doch schon in der folge
erwähnt
das aber ist das ist es hier unseres was
einmal warte mal bist du hier rein in
die eine hülle die hinter unserem dinges
jaja da war ich dran
das war ich sicher dazu verlaufen ja da
sind von peer bork vom ok ok gut kommt
mit zwei eingängen
ich dachte schon werden uns da bin ich
mit ihm an die gleiche stelle man sich
was ich sagen wollte
das war tatsächlich so konya das auch in
der folge erwähnt und dann war das nach
zur vorm einschlafen lag im bett und
dann kam es zu dem moment wo stalder wir
müssen das unbedingt zensieren und habe
ich ihn noch eine eine sprachnachrichten
boards darüber gebummelt
diese leute wendet ihn sprache tiegs
weise und dann sehen die unten sind die
online und hören die sich die einfach
nicht an
beispiel kinos ich habe mir alle immer
immer alles an alles ich glaube mir
nicht ich glaube wir müssen die bäume
fällen um äpfel zu bekommen das könnte
es sein aber vielleicht mache ich
einfach hier noch ein bisschen monster
schnetzeln zum ende dieser episode und
dann ist eigentlich auch gut ich bin
wieder ein bisschen egal ob wir wirklich
da könnte ja nicht der besuch der drei
glaube ich nicht auf die kette entweder
über die bücher oder über die tagtäglich
voll benutzt habt die zwar nicht ganz
günstig ist aber trotzdem halt was
bringt das dass das wird schon das wird
das wird ich bin mir sicher dass das
wird katy perry vor allem wo du es dir
gerade seine mutter die ich immer
vorwärts anfeuert ich habe jetzt im
erdgeschoss main oder gaben geld
wirklich anderen fragt mich einfach nur
bis zur geistig behindert weil ich
geschrieben habe
wir aber auch draußen angekommen wo er
in seinen händen hält seit fünf jahren
dabei kilos manager vollmitglied ist
unglaublich wie es läuft denn da machen
wir erst mal gleich schön und rüstungen
noch also ich finde rüst und ist auf dem
griechischen markt und ihre macht du dir
was ich habe ja schon wieder india
schwer treffer ein zusammengebastelt
dann kannst du dir dann kannst du jetzt
auch eine rüstung hier leisten und dann
werde ich ihn nicht erwiesen
was das ist 15 minuten ich würde eine
menge eine halbe minute dran bis 17
minuten ich spring spring zurück ins
lager kompletten sekunden drauf
in diesem stück man kann ja nie wissen
ob ich habe mir und habe gedacht hey
guck mal darüber culinary folge jetzt
auch schon online ist wo wir vorher
waren dürfen jetzt sogar noch eine
aufnahme
jetzt war da war das sind jetzt drei im
voraus wir dürfen keine männer nach man
ja stimmen 3 und das sind das ist das
sind jetzt sind jetzt drei im voraus
genau das sind pünktlich genau 31 also
wir können dann zum letzten mal gemacht
haben wieder mit der taktik machen dass
wir in der nächsten folge umziehen und
ich finde unser haus gar nicht wieder
wir haben auch kein haus wir besitzen
einfach keiner aus da ist es das
stadthaus
ich komme rein und mache gleich wieder
die kürzung 123 und dann können wir
gleich geblieben diese diese folge
beenden und zwar möglichst schnell damit
nichts passiert und auch schon wieder
ist das sogar gewachsen
schön da kann ich das mit den büchern
verzaubern ich sowieso nicht disconnect
oliver korn und dann youngster guck mir
sind ja noch bei minute 16
wir dürfen den kredit runter ich will
nicht noch mal geben ihren also ich will
auch unter wenn es euch gefallen
positive werte oder wir werden immer
besser wir haben es auch schon richtig
viele diamant machen und rüstungsteile
und wir haben sogar noch eine minute
zeit
also ich denke nicht dass ein projekt so
eine minute dauern ich liebe dich wir
sind richtig richtig gut aber ich finde
das wird laufen dieses projekt und sonst